what's going on guys this is rob and
marvel battle lines reach out to me
asking me to tell you guys about their
game which you can find a link for down
in the description so model battle lines
features an innovative approach to the
card battle genre through its dynamic
three by four game board that players
will compete on through single-player
missions and player versus player
matches now the general idea is that by
placing and forming a line with your
Marvel characters on this board they'll
activate a battle line attack which will
deal damage to your opponent and when
your opponent's life reaches zero you
end
now not only that the game launches with
over 200 unique cards and you can
collect and build decks of different
super heroes and super villains and the
favorites are all here
Iron Man Black Panther venom and
Squirrel Girl are just to name a few
now the game itself features an
expansive roster of characters that true
Marvel enthusiasts like myself would
definitely recognize like Deathlok Man
Thing and grin pool and so make sure you
guys check out the link in the
description to get your hands on Marvel
battle lines for the iPhone iPad and
Android devices so what I want to do
here is have a discussion about the
various cosmic entities of the onew all
different mobile prime universe starting
with colitis and what I'm hoping is that
at the end of all this you'll have a
strong understanding of his character
relative to the number of issues that we
have as well as how his involvement in
the new universe actually helps us to
understand how things relate to the pre
secret wars universe
so the all-new all-different Galactus
comes to us as part of Al Ewing's
all-new all-different Ultimates and
while I will have a video on that team
as part of a lead-up to Civil War to
what Al Ewing does here is actually
really interesting to sidetrack for a
second when Galactus first debuted in
the original Marvel Universe well he
wasn't provided an origin in his first
few appearances the explanation of his
existence came by way of Thor vol 1
issues 168 through 170 originally
established as being a universal
Explorer named gallon in the earth Co
continuity at the end of that universes
life Galactus remained the sole survivor
merging with that reality's version of
eternity during this birthing process
Galactus had fashioned a vessel for
himself allowing an incubation period of
several million years where he gathered
his energies constructed a suit to
contain those energies and emerged as a
Galactus that we all know and love
consuming planets to sustain his life
now all the reasons for Galactus being a
cosmic necessity have changed over the
years ranging from a meta commentary on
his representation of life death and
rebirth as well as a physical force
whose death unleashed Abraxas who
threatened the multiverse on the whole a
Ewing does not actually provide us with
an expansive origin and the Marvel prime
universe while there are different
explanations that could be offered for
this and truth I would surmise that with
Galactus being such a well-known
character even if his origin is only
slightly understood by casual readers
it's still understood and so the
information provided actually just gives
us a one-page synopsis sticking with a
classic story of Galactus hailing from
the earth zero continuity and that said
because the Ultimates exist to in threat
to the universe but to also boost an
anticipation for the start of the series
the first being encountered by The
Ultimates came in the form of Galactus
taking place in issues number one and
number two in November in December of
2015 as the official launch title and a
self contained story what we're told is
that from the perspective of blue Marvel
and black panther Galactus is hunger is
not a requirement for him instead this
is a byproduct of the incubation period
meaning this process could be reversed
now somebody take note of here is that
al Ewing is taking certain liberties and
that as far as I'm aware the hunger of
Galactus is an intrinsic part of his
character and no one had ever created a
story where his hunger was depicted as
something that could be cured the only
exception to this that I can think of
came in the first six issues of the 2003
Thanos solo series by jim Starlin which
depicted Galactus as hunger as a
multiversal entity working through
Galactus and attempting to consume
realities however because this story
arch stretched the limits of credulity
even by comic standards fans don't
generally consider it to be canon or in
existence now in terms of The Ultimates
after putting their efforts together
black panther and blue Marvel reasoned
that if Galactus is hunger emerged
following his time in the incubation
chamber the hunger could be reversed by
forcing Galactus back into the chamber
to this end the Ultimates BACtrack
Galactus his time as a devourer of
worlds eventually arriving at our key
Opia the first planet Galactus it
consumed after emerging scavenging the
dead world and reconstructing the
incubation chamber the entirety of the
alter
including Carol Danvers Monica Rambeau
America Chavez and Black Panther
combined their powers in an effort to
force Galactus back into his chamber
emerging as a life bringer at the
conclusion of issue number 2 valuing
established that instead of consuming
worlds and ending life Galactus now
functions as the source of life creating
and healing worlds he had previously
consumed beginning with our key obeah
following this and going into the next
five titles leading up to issue number
seven as the most current release the
Ultimates line served to provide to plot
the first following the Ultimates
themselves and leading into civil war
two for the second following Galactus
and an explanation of the all-new
all-different marvel prime universe
picking up an issue number four
following the Ultimates attempts to
understand the space-time continuum in
the post secret wars continuity the
likeness himself was contacted by
eternity who advised of the ultimate
actions and that they could not proceed
visiting the team amidst their journey
into the previous realm of the beyonders
which now exists as a void of
nothingness al Ewing begins the first
steps of referencing the pre secret wars
universe where Carol Danvers offers the
explanation that the team sought to
understand the space-time continuum
Galactus provides her with a glimpse of
how he sees time establishing that were
model had never officially provided an
answer the fact remains that secret wars
was not a reboot
instead the events that took place in
the earth-616 universe still happened
but secret wars allow for reshuffling of
characters in realities this comes with
the fact that as Galactus shows us the
death of the original Captain Marvel the
Iron Man armor Wars and the onslaught
saga are memories that he still
maintains at the same time he also makes
reference to Marvel sliding time scale
and the idea of retcons to sidetrack
with marvel's publications it was
standard practice for them to include
dates and references to presidents
throughout the 1960s and 1970s but with
the 1980 seeing their final reference to
a concrete period in the real world from
that point going forward all absolute
dates of reference were eliminated what
this meant was that instead of saying
Civil War happened in a certain year and
during a certain month instead the event
would take place with future stories
referencing it as a year or three years
ago as a result between 1984 and the
current day
everything within marvel comic's is
assumed to have taken place within a
10-year window in addition to this
Galactus states that the past is never
concrete and then it can always be
changed now this is really more of a
meta commentary on retroactive
continuities and the idea that various
writers will alter the history of models
past in order to suit an existing story
or to introduce a character as an
example within the Marvel Universe
itself
blue Marvel did not exist until 2009
when Kevin Bravo had created him and
altered the history of Marvel to
establish that Adam Brashear was
Marvel's first black superhero now while
I do have a video explaining these
concepts in more detail for those who
still find them a little confusing with
a Galactus forcing the heroes to sleep
and returning them to the main universe
he's called before eternity who reveals
that he's being kept in Chains and was
placed in this position by an unknown
being now something actually want to do
here is I want to step away from this
for a minute and I want to have a
discussion on the role of eternity in
the new Marvel prime universe within the
old universe eternity existed as a
singular being and a physical
manifestation of each universe that
existed however because doom had created
battleworld during Secret Wars while the
planet was composed of different
realities instead of battleworld having
a version of eternity for each territory
the whole of battleworld combined to
allow for singular entity who was kept
under the control of dues power now this
is particularly important due to the
fact that the fan community was largely
split over the idea of a multiversal
version of eternity existing under the
Living Tribunal and serving to represent
the multiverse itself holding it all
together while the idea of a multiverse
eternity was alluded to but never really
confirmed prior to and during Secret
Wars with Al Ewing's Ultimates his
information reveals that after the
destruction of battle world and the
creation of the multiverse by Owen Reese
Franklin Richards and Reed Richards
a multiverse whole eternity came into
existence holding the multiverse
together under the New Living Tribunal
and spawning the cosmic entities and so
with a multiverse itself in Chains
Galactus was tasked with discovering who
it was it did this and how to restore
things to normal
picking up with issue number six where
Galactus continues his quest as it was
assigned by eternity during his travels
he encounters master order and Lord
chaos as the representations of order
and chaos
work against one another and maintain
universal balance through their conflict
because galactus had previously been
known as the world devourer to the mind
of lord chaos Galactus represented
destruction and catastrophe but for
master order the destruction of Galactus
was part of the cosmic order allowing
for the death of planets and the balance
of the universal population and but
because he has vacated that role and
stepped into the position of the life
bringer
Lord chaos is no longer satisfied due to
Galactus failing to inflict destruction
the master order is unsatisfied due to
Galactus stepping away from the status
quo to this end the entities transported
Galactus to the SuperFlow which existed
as a space between realities with the
intention of forcing the lactis back
into his position and however because
master order and Lord chaos exists in
such rigid forms with Galactus
maintaining free will the two entities
are completely overpowered and forced to
retrieve after which Galactus is brought
before Owen Reese the molecule man now
for this bit of the discussion what we
have previously engaged in a bit of meta
commentary the conversation between
Galactus and Owen Reese is extremely
important due to the fact that molecule
man will actually address the reader
base directly and the community's view
of the all-new all-different universe
while molecule man gets extremely wordy
and goes as far as to use a modified
version of the Schrodinger's cat thought
experiment the long and short of this is
that molecule man addresses the issue of
model existing in a state of flux to
sidetrack here the thought experiment of
Schrodinger's cat is a concept in
quantum mechanics offering the idea that
if an unobserved action occurs any and
all possibilities of that action are
available however once that observation
occurs an absolute answer is provided
and the question is definitively
answered while this may seem a little
confusing to simplify things molecule
man is saying that the problem with the
current universe is that it was rebooted
but it wasn't rebooted furthermore there
are some beings within the universe who
do not remember the events of the
multiversal collapse and seeker wars but
there are also some who do as a result
there are those who believed that the
multiverse did collapse and was
recreated but there are also those that
don't and what al Ewing is doing here is
offering a statement to us and Marvel
saying that you can't have it both ways
you can't shuffle some characters around
introduce new teams and
our conflicting memories all while
calling it a reboot if you haven't
actually rebooted anything either it's a
reboot or it's not what I want to do
here is I want to talk about The
Ultimates more specifically this second
storyline basically focuses on two
aspects it focuses on the return of
Thanos and it focuses on Galactus
creating a new Herald and so I'm still
not sure which one of those titles I'm
gonna pitch but the idea here is that
for those of you guys who don't know
with Marvel Comics The Ultimates are
like this this multiversal group they're
like the avengers on a much grander
scale now The Ultimates don't exist in
the multiverse it's not like you know
the members hail from different
universes and the Marvel multiverse they
all hail from the earth-616 universe but
the idea behind this is to have them
face threats from across the multiverse
that threatened the main Marvel
earth-616 reality the issue with this is
that there there is much a defensive
measure as they are an exploratory team
and so the goal here is to to basically
face off against threats that most
people can't deal with that's one of the
reasons why we have such powerhouse
characters that's what we have Carol
Danvers that's why we have the
intelligence of Black Panther that's why
we have Adam Brashear we have spectrum
we have America Chavez we have some
really really powerful beings here and
the idea is that again they're designed
to step up against multiversal threats
now we had talked in my video about the
all-new all-different Galactus that
their first task was to basically
eliminate the hunger of Galactus due to
the fact that by Galactus traveling
around the universe and consuming worlds
that he and of himself was destructive
the issue with this is that a Ewing I
imagine would have in some form or
fashion whether he knew about it through
a retcon or whether he somebody just
didn't know about it or didn't care it
begs the question how do the Celestials
fit into this because those are guys who
don't know in Marvel Comics Celestials
quite literally plant eggs in worlds and
they will emerge after some million
years or however long it is but Galactus
running around and consuming worlds is
just as much a safeguard for the
universe as it is for him consuming his
own hunger because if he wasn't
consuming worlds then it would result in
these and Celestials running rampant
throughout the cosmos so the idea is is
to basically keep things from going
insane and having said that because this
second volume is part of the civil war
too
event one of the interesting things
about this is that the tie-ins they're a
little lackluster but it's also a good
way that Marvel has done it instead of
tying them directly into Civil War two
which would mean no that we will
basically have to hold off all the
volumes until Civil War 2 comes out
instead they basically just reference
the events of Civil War 2 but things are
still going on in their individual
stories and so in truth the Civil War to
tie ends are really standalone stories
you don't really have to read the main
Civil War 2 story in order to read the
the second volume of all these different
publications x-23 and Avengers and so on
and so forth it can't hurt you know to
read civil war 2 as it goes on but it's
not a requirement and so what ultimate
what this second issue does or I guess
the second run does is it initially
picks up with a character called the
infinite now we don't really know
anything about this guy but what al
Ewing does is he initially jumps back to
1998 with Adam Brashear working
alongside as his son Kevin now Adam
Fisher of course we know is a
genius-level scientist his intelligence
isn't necessarily up there with black
panther but he's not that far off and so
his son Kevin had very much followed his
footsteps in terms of pursuing you know
these paths of science and now the
result was that it seemed to be these
these incursions or these many a
temporal wakes that resulted in some
being trying to enter the Marvel
earth-616 continuity and so because this
has been going on for decades
I don't brush here alongside of son had
been working to try to prevent this from
happening now the other half of this
though is that an embrasure son Kevin
had at one point vanished which is one
of the reasons why we hadn't seen him
for so long
during the early issues of his run in
Marvel Comics with Mighty Avengers and
so on and so forth he was eventually
brought back but he wasn't he didn't
quite operate in the same capacity that
he did in this but again this is really
just a Ewing setting things up but
because of the fact that this highs into
Civil War to the main event itself
focuses on a character named Ulysses who
is an inhuman with the ability to
predict the future now as we discussed
in my Steve Rogers Captain America video
these predictions are not 100% accurate
but they're close enough that Carol
Danvers is willing to gamble on the
accuracy of these in order to basically
stop crimes before they happen or to
stop incidents before they happen now
because of the arrival of Ulysses it's
to turn the tables on how it is an Adam
Beshear views these temporal risks with
regards to this info not trying to come
through but previously it seemed like it
was a threat instead
and Anna Brashear begins to look at it
as the very basis behind the Ultimates
charter in the sense that their
exploratory their investigators their
problem solvers and so with the initial
idea here is that this machine is being
developed with a combination of the
ultimate steam as a whole in order to
stop this danger
Adam Brashear realizes that it's
actually to figure things out and so
what happens is that when this rift
opens up they basically reach out to
this humanoid being to the infinite and
they bring him in and Adam Brashear
states to everybody that the case with
this is that he's basically just a
scientist as a scientist from another
universe that was exploring the
multiverse and the Ultimates can learn
just as much from infinite as infinite
can learn from them and so because of
this is really not a danger but it falls
in line with the ideology of The
Ultimates in terms of looking at
problems and trying to get them figured
out finding solutions as over here we
jump to Connor Sims now for those of you
guys who have seen my video on atom
brashears character with his first
appearance as it was written by Kevin
Griffo the experiment that gave Adam
Breshears powers also gave Connor sims's
powers the difference here is that for
all intents and purposes when it comes
to just sheer raw power
Connor Sims is pretty far beyond Adam
Brashear Connor Sims has the ability to
manipulate antimatter which is the
opposite of normal matter but it still
allows him the ability to manipulate
atoms on a subatomic scale and so he's
basically a character who can warp
reality the issue with this is that
counter Sims was eventually what or at
least was initially believed to have
been destroyed during atom brashears
first encounter I guess the the story
the final encounter with him but it
wasn't until a Ewing came back and wrote
The Ultimates that he revealed that
Connor Sims was alive he was just out in
space somewhere and no one knew about it
but Connor Sims himself didn't really
know what was going on now the reason
seemed to be based on the idea of seeker
wars when Reed Richards had restored the
multiverse that Connor Sims memories
were wiped but then we learned that
Connor Sims did remember everything he
remembered all the things that he had
done but he had also come to a
realization and the realization he had
come to was that eternity had been
chained at some cosmic force out there
which seems to be more powerful than
eternity had chained all of reality or
chained the universe itself and the idea
of Connor symbols that it had driven him
insane by knowing this or at least not
traditionally insane but in a driven him
to the brink of madness in the sense of
his mind couldn't quite grasp it because
he had come to the realization there's a
being out there of such incredible power
and it's not a being that's kind
it's a being that is dangerous it's a
being that seems to be evil and so
because Connor Sims doesn't see the
world the same way people do the thing
that we normally do because he sees the
world and atomic particles he sees the
world in terms of its molecular
structure and matter and energy and so
on and so forth he basically came to the
realization that there's like a giant
barrier around the universe that they
can't get out of and so someone is
basically turned the Marvel earth-616
universe into a giant prison and he's
trying to figure out a way to get out
but he's also overwhelmed by this and so
what happens is that while he is you
know being held at confinement of his
own free will due to the fact that he's
afraid of his power sort of just
breaking loose in an unbridled fashion
he's immediately met by the arrival of
Thanos now the other half of this is
that in the events leading up to civil
war to Thanos had attacked the planet
Earth in pursuit of the Cosmic Cube that
had been created by shield which is what
led to Avengers standoff and the
recreation of Steve Rogers past again we
have that in my video on on Captain
America Steve Rogers but Thanos had been
captured by a combination of the
Avengers and The Ultimates and had been
held prisoner under the Ultimates base
of operations which is called the
Triskelion and so because of this when
Connor Sims had arrived and Thanos had
come to the realization of just how
powerful Connor Sims is he began to
devise a plan to basically manipulate
Connor Sims and not only freeing him but
then turning hunter Sims into a puppet
for his own goals and so while Connor
Sims is dealing with his own you know
emotions and the overwhelming nature of
what's happening with things Santos
appears to him and begins manipulating
him now this is when al Ewing starts to
incorporate a lot of things in terms of
what's going on with Thanos right now
because all we really had with his
reimburses was that he was just there he
was looking for a cosmic cube he was
defeated he had killed James Rhodes he
had injured she hook and then he was
taken prisoner and that was it we didn't
really have anything to go on here we
knew that because of the fact that
mistress death had barred him from the
realm of death it basically made him
effectively immortal that when the
restoration of the multiverse happened
by Reed Richards at the end of secret
Wars that he was just thrown outside of
all reality he was thrown into the realm
of nothingness basically and that's when
he really didn't really know anything
else besides that and so what this did
is this turned into a question of what
happens next what happens with Thanos
now and this is what we get Thanos
basically says that over the course of
his life
he had fallen in love with mistress
death that was that was his big claim to
fame
that was his huge staple before Secret
Wars it was his pursuit of the
affections of mistress death it's why he
gained the Infinity Gauntlet and wiped
out half the life in the universe that's
why he pursued the Cosmic Cube is what
he did all these things because he
wanted the affections of mistress death
the other half of this was that when he
was outside of the multiverse he
basically fell in love with a what it
seems to be an entity called nothingness
now we know virtually nothing about this
I mean we don't know if nothingness is
even an entity or if it's just the idea
that Thanos has just fallen to the point
where he's just in love with the idea of
destroying all things in existence we
have no idea what direction Al Ewing is
going with this but basically Ewing has
taken Thanos and removed him from his
love with mistress death and so while
this is going on all these go to
encounter Sims we ended up finding that
the ultimate in and of themselves are
fighting one another and the reason why
is because with Ulysses predicting that
a briefcase the contents of a briefcase
was going to lead to a massive amount of
destruction that Carol Danvers had
organized the Ultimates and pursuing a
woman named Alison green now this is
basically Al Ewing or at least it seems
to be al you ain't telling us that
Connor Sims is not always right and the
reason why is because while there's some
disagreement while the soldiers of Carol
Danvers are a little more harsh than
they need to be and it creates a little
bit of rivalry between the Ultimates
themselves when they get the briefcase
back and they open it up they realize
there's nothing there and this just
creates a huge amount of backlash in the
team it really leads like the
destruction of the team in traditional
means because of the fact that no one
agrees Carol Danvers says hey look like
we're trying to stop crimes yes they
haven't done anything now but a guy who
says he could see the future and he's
been accurate so far so it means that if
he says they're going to do something
then they're likely going to now what's
interesting about this and this is one
of the reasons why like a lot of fans at
the moment hate Carol Danvers because in
the face of a briefcase that's empty in
the face of the fact that Ulysses was
wrong she refuses to accept that she
simply just says no no he's right it's
just you know he was talking about a
different briefcases all it was he was
talking about something else but he's
been right 90% of the time and so even
if he's wrong 10% of the time it's
better to lock up innocent people than
to let guilty people go free and that's
basically what she's saying here that's
the cases she's making that yes innocent
people will go to jail but it's a lesser
of two evils it's worth the risk
and so because of this Wallace
thanos is quite literally showing all
this infighting to counter sims because
connor sims is of such a mind right now
because of the things that he's done
he's convinced that no one will believe
him and Thanos feeds on that he says
look I mean they're fighting amongst
themselves they can't even agree on how
to save the world what makes you think
they're going to agree that you're
telling the truth about eternity being
confined in Chains you know and so
Connor Sims again is a little unsure
about a situation but he says Santos is
the only way for them to know the truth
it's for you to show them the truth and
so what happens is he basically escapes
from his cell and he allows his power to
just explode not in the sense of you
know of maximum capacity if he did that
he would probably destroy the universe
but he allows his power to explode to an
extent that it basically overrides the
energies of the Triskelion basically
shutting it down all the reason why he
does this is because this cell that he's
confined in was designed explicitly to
keep his powers in check the issue with
this is that no one knew how powerful he
was when Adam Brashear had faced off
against an T man he had an idea of how
powerful he was but he was really
fighting an T man on the atomic level as
opposed to fighting him on the level of
power that he possessed and so because
of this we didn't know what it was that
he was capable of and with an embrasure
not knowing the full extent of Connor
Sims powers it came to fruition that
counter Sims just broke out of his cell
and so because of the fact that he broke
out of his cell because of the fact that
the confinements of Thanos were no
longer powered he was able to break out
of his containment unit and basically
start wreaking havoc within the Tris
kinda this is one of the best parts of
the whole story this is amazing because
this is classic Thanos I mean when
people think of Thanos this is what they
think of Thanos with the Infinity
Gauntlet school Thanos with you of
cosmic qubit school the best Thanos is
Thanos when he's cornered is when he
when he basically has to fight his way
out that's the best Thanos not only
because of the fact that he's so capable
in terms of his abilities but because of
the fact that he is he's ruthless and
he's intelligent and so again he
basically begins to tell us here or at
least when the ultimate show up he goads
Connor Sims now a couple things to point
out here is that the powers of the
ultimate complement one another what I
mean by this is that at one point in the
history of her character a Carol Danvers
went by the name of binary whereby she
was able to absorb cosmic energies or
absorb any kind of energy and then
channel those back out
as cosmic energies now in truth this was
just Chris Claremont's way of trying to
reinvent her character Thoreau on the
x-men team and hope it would boost her
popularity it really didn't hurt her
comics were just routinely canceled and
what we're seeing right now with all-new
all-different marvel is about a
successful as she's been since her run
and Marvel now where she officially
became Captain Marvel but before that
she really was not a very successful
character people knew who she was but
she couldn't hold a title to save her
life and so what ultimately happens here
is Adam Brashear uses his energies to
manipulate positive matter channels them
into Carol Danvers and she basically now
has cosmic level powers the kicker about
this is that it doesn't matter with a
nose Thanos is still able to take her
out not only that she's able to use her
energies to channel them into spectrum
in order to allow spectrum who is
basically living energy to go into the
mind of Thanos and try to override his -
it was a little bit like a chain
reaction
Adam Brashear feeds Carol Danvers who in
turn feeds spectrum but when spectrum
enters the mind of Thanos she realizes
that his mental energies are way too
much for her to be able to cope with
they're beyond a level she can even
begin to comprehend and that's true this
character oh you ain't snot retconning
anything here it's always been that way
Thanos his mental energies his mental
powers you know not necessarily
telepathy different things like that but
just the abilities he's capable of by
using his mind have always been his
greatest feat his intelligence so on and
so forth when spectrum goes into his
mind she's literally overwhelmed and he
in turn takes the energy that was being
pushed into him by spectrum and sends
that energy back out and shoots it at
Adam Brashear so it's like this giant
circle you know Adam Brashear charges
Carol Danvers who charges spectrum who
forces her energy zonda Thanos who in
turn takes those energies and shoots
Adam Brashear now the reason why this is
an important thing when it comes to
Thanos is because he always is at the
top of his game when it comes to battle
and so because of the fact that he
realized that Adam Bashir was the one
who is making all of this possible in
the first place
taking him out means that Carol Danvers
would not be in her position of binary
and it also means that spectrum wouldn't
be nearly as powerful now the funny
thing about all this is that T'Challa is
watching all this unfold now in terms of
his intelligence T'Challa
is pretty smart and I would say he's
probably smarter than tano's just
because of the fact that when it comes
to the top you know five smartest people
in the Marvel Universe
Thanos ranks it like number six or
number seven while Panther is in the top
three as far as I'm aware
so because of this Black Panthers just
kind of watching things unfold but even
while The Ultimates are doing the best
they can to face off against him danos
is just trashing him he's trashing them
all one by one
and this just shows you how capable he
is that he's going against America
Chavez who can open portals she can feed
off energy he's going toe to toe with
Adam Brashear who's literally a guy that
can manipulate particles you know he's
going against Carol Danvers who striketh
is on par with the Incredible Hulk in
arrested form I mean he's going against
everybody and doing his own and so
because of the fact that the charla is
so intelligent he comes to the
realization that they can't fight Thanos
with brute force there's no way they're
going to stand a chance if Thanos can
stand toe-to-toe with the Incredible
Hulk they can't beat him and so the only
way to defeat him is to use their minds
to use their wits and do the best they
can and so what happens here is they
basically shut off access to his mind
they more or less use a mental
projection or a user use mental energies
the kind of energies that were designed
to keep Connor Sims contained and they
in turn project those mental energies
and Athan owes and quite literally sever
the I guess electronic synopses they
basically shut off his brain's ability
to function is essentially what they do
now under normal circumstances in
T'Challa tells us this under normal
circumstances shutting off the brain of
Thanos would have killed him but as we
know he's been barred from the realm of
mistress death and so he's basically
just in a catatonic state now this is al
Ewing saving Thanos this is basically
him just saying hey we're going to use
him later on we're not gonna remove this
piece from the chessboard yet because
he's too good you know he's not
necessarily the queen but he's certainly
a bishop or a rook and so we're not
going to remove him yet because he's a
guy that we need to use later on now
this will probably feed into some
massive crossover event because as most
any Marvel fan will tell you for those
of you guys who were new as most any
veteran Marvel comic fan will tell you
if there's any one person in the cosmos
to have on your team when it comes to
matters of intelligence Thanos is one of
the guys that you want in your corner I
mean you know perfect case scenario
you've got Thanos and Galactus and all
the cosmic entities you know but if I
had to pick one Thanos would be my guy
just because of his experience because
of what he's capable of and so because
of this you know the The Ultimates
initially go back to bickering with one
another they go back to arguing with one
another but following Thanos attacking
The Ultimates Roo prior to him attacking
the ultimate Connor Sims had just taken
off and so we didn't really know where
he had went to we didn't really know
what had happened with him but then what
we do is we transition to him as things
begin to wrap up and we find that he had
just kind of traveled into deep space
and he's taking some time to think about
everything that's going on but he's also
overwhelmed by the gravity of things
because in the mind of Connor Sims civil
war 2 is happening the superheroes are
fighting on planet Earth
because some inhuman can see the future
but for him he's like there's much
bigger things to worry about like there
is a threat out there to the universe
likely even to the multiverse and so it
was like why are you fighting over this
this is more or less the civil war -
equivalent to annihilation from Civil
War 1 and what I mean by that is those
two guys who don't know while the Civil
War one event was taking place with
Captain America and Tony Stark fighting
one another the villain Annihilus had
discovered the negative zones equivalent
of the power cosmic the energy that
Galactus wields and Annihilus had
invaded the earth-616 universe and was
literally petting a swath through the
universe I mean just wiping out planet
after planet this is wiping out life all
over the place it was really like
guerrilla warfare tactics it was last
battle at the Alamo it was the the
various cosmic forces doing the best
they could to just survive and the
heroes on earth were fighting about
superhuman Registration that's basically
what's happening with this story right
now or at least that's what al Ewing
seems to be leading up to that's one
reason why I love the ultimate so much
because it's a huge cosmic event that's
going on out here while they're just
fighting about civil war - it's really
setting the landscape for much bigger
things and so as it begins to fall
through these dimensional doorways he
begins to recall on things this question
is what happened here what being exists
out there that possesses such incredible
power that they're able to completely
take over and to chain the universe
itself because in the mind of Connor
Sims with his experience throughout the
multiverse his experience traveling
outside of all space and time the only
people capable of doing this are like
The Living Tribunal and the one above
all but apparently not apparently
somebody else is able to do that we know
it's not the molecule man Owen Reese or
at least a business seemed to be that
way but as he continues to fall down
through things because his power is on
such an extreme degree if there was
anyone that could face off against this
multiversal being that's capable of
attaining eternity it would probably be
Connor Sims but Connor Sims going
outside and battling this this entity
would Polynesia
in the destruction of the multiverse not
only that galactus was tasked by
eternity to make sure no one knew what
was going on now why attorney who did
that we don't know and so in response to
Connor Sims falling through you know
these dimensional barriers and falling
outside of all existence Galactus
retrieves him and Galactus transforms
him into his new Herald not only that
what he also says is go get the
Ultimates
go find me the Ultimates because I'm
going to make them heralds as well and
this is basically just Galactus building
an army for himself using his power
cosmic is him creating what looks like
it's going to be six different heralds
for the purpose of leading a campaign
against whatever this multiverse allure
this omnipotent being happens to be that
managed to chain up eternity okay so I
absolutely love Ultimates like it's it's
I think really one of the standout
titles and all-new all-different marvel
and Marvel now 2.0 the sad thing is that
like not a lot of people know about it
or they don't know what's going on in it
and so because of that they're just like
missing out on this amazing stuff so I'm
really hoping this video will serve the
purpose of letting you guys know what's
going on and you guys will go out and
buy it because it is an awesome title so
for those of the guys who were curious
about like cosmic Marvel about like
eternity and Galactus and all that kind
of stuff this takes care of all that
Ultimates covers all that we've covered
all the ultimate stuff up to this point
but it covers all that but the big
question that people have had is who
chained eternity that was the big
question we saw in all-new all-different
Ultimates that somebody had basically
put eternity the living embodiment of
the multiverse in Chains now what Al
Ewing is doing here is actually offered
a little bit of a change with regards to
the Eternity concept and we'll get to
that once we get further into this video
because what we're basically going to
get is the origin of everything that's
ever existed in Marvel Comics from the
time the very first universe took form
up until the collapse of the multiverse
now and what not really what happened
but in terms of some of the history of
the various different multiverses that
have existed in between so it'll all
make sense by the time we get to it I
won't be confusing in any way but the
idea here is that we initially pick up
with Adam Brashear with blue Marvel
officially it is kind of like you know
staring into and trying to figure out
what's going on with everything because
remember the Ultimates basically
disbanded during
the events of civil war - when carol
danvers was using the ultimate as a way
to basically carry out her goal of
keeping crime from happening before it
happened of course you list these and
all that kind of good stuff but because
of the fact that a lot of people hated
civil war - but what a ewing ended up
doing was basically bringing the
ultimates back together to answer the
question of who chained eternity and it
was only when the Ultimates had learned
this had happened they began to ask the
question of what was going on now from
this point we transition over to over to
Monica Rambeau and the funny thing about
Monica Rambeau is spectrum is that
historically she's played a lot of
different roles I mean she's been
captain universe I believe I want to say
she was Captain Marvel at one point um
but the whole idea here often she was
captain universe I think she was just
Captain Marvel um I think it was on
confusing her with the girl from
Hickman's Avengers of New Avengers the
random chick who was in a car wreck and
and suddenly saved by the Cynthia's of
the universe and became Captain universe
well cover that next year but Monica
Rambeau is played Captain Marvel for a
time and and the whole idea is that she
was always kind of considered to be a
throwaway character by a lot of readers
in the sense that she never really
received her time in the Sun and the
cool thing about this is that she
actually gets it because what al Ewing
has really been harping on with her
character is how powerful she is that
she is in effect pure energy that the
physical body that we see is not her
true form that Adam Brashear looks at
her and sees her for what she really is
which is basically just pure energy in
the form of a human meaning she can
basically do anything now we kind of
knew that with her character to a degree
in a sense because she was able to
manipulate all facets of the energy
spectrum she could turn into anything
any form of energy she could use any
form of energy that kind of thing but I
mean she can't like warp reality on a
universal scale like she can't
manipulate molecules or anything like
that she's effectively just a giant
battery and so it's really really cool
to see what kind of limits her powers
can be pushed to but again in the midst
of all this what is it up happening is
Monica's basically just kind of whisked
away and all of it seems to have been
done by Connor Sims now again Connor
Sims as we know him is basically an T
man of course we covered him during the
the origin story of blue Marvel but he
had since been turned into a Herald of
Galactus and the reason why was because
Galactus realizing that eternity had
been chained but not knowing who it was
that did it basically said if there is a
being out there that can chain eternity
then I need a new Herald and that Herald
is going to go to the ultimate breathe
to me and make them my heralds and so
the idea of Galactus was to use the
ultimate asses heralds essentially
functioning as protectors of the
universe the way it existed now and
that's exactly what happens the various
Ultimates are basically whisked away by
Connor Sims to a Galactus ship tattoo
and they're met with America Chavez who
basically says look there is a mass of a
massive threat coming and we have to
find a way to deal with this now America
Chavez is one of these characters who's
only ever really as interesting as a
story that she's in she's not inherently
interesting by herself we know this
because ultimate like America number one
came out sold really well and then
America number two tanked so she's just
not really an interesting character but
for what she does here in the ultimate
this makes her interesting and that's
what I say and Marvel Comics a lot of
the characters are not inherently
intriguing
it's the events surrounding them that
make them intriguing for example Captain
universe is not an intriguing character
but it's Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers that make make a Captain
universe intriguing the same thing with
star brand and night masks and a lot of
those characters it's the events going
on around them that make them
interesting as opposed to just the
characters themselves now of course
America Chavez being here is basically
saying there's something wrong with the
multiverse there's some threat out there
in the multiverse that's screwing
everything up and we are going to have
to try to find a way to essentially fix
it now of course the other half of this
is that a Galactus encounter Sims
basically take off and they actually end
up meeting directly with a lady tribunal
and master order in Lord Chaos now the
reason why this happens is because of
the fact that we'd seen this before in
the previous discussion of that the
previous videos that we've done that the
first problem the ultimate solved is
basically solving all the problems in
the universe
the first proud a major problem they
solved was Galactus they looked at
Galactus and they said him being the
devourer of worlds is a threat to all
life in existence what we're going to do
is we're basically going to evolve him
into his perfect form and make him the
life bringer now the reason why Galactus
being made the life bringer was such a
huge deal in terms of the contents of
this story is that from the perspective
of master order and Lord chaos they
represent opposing size right I mean
we've had this discussion countless
times and we'll have this discussion
again when we basically remaster
Infinity Gauntlet and when we do
infinity war and all that cosmic stuff
next year the whole idea is that the
universe is basically in balance there
is order and there's chaos and you can't
have one without the other a perfectly
ordered universe would look crazy a
perfect
the chaotic universe would look just as
crazy jim Starlin showed us those two
things when we basically went inside the
minds of Thanos and Adam warlock to see
a perfect universe in Adam warlocks mind
and a chaotic universe and Thanos is
mine so because of this they basically
work in unison the issue here is that in
the mind in the perspective of master
order and Lord chaos Galactus is
supposed to be the devourer of worlds
that's his role in the universe that's
the role that he plays in the same way
that master order are an order and Lord
chaos play the role of two opposites
with the in-betweener being the
reconciliation between order and chaos
in the same way that eternity plays the
role of being the living embodiment of
the universe and so on Galactus is
supposed to play the role of the world
of our now because of the fact that he's
not doing this they end up invoking the
Living Tribunal because remember the
Living Tribunal is basically the judge
whenever there's a cosmic disagreement
the Living Tribunal is invoked and the
tribunal will determine whether or not
the actions of a being is are basically
in violation of cosmic order which is to
say if there were a being that were nigh
uncatchable would say this person is not
part of the cosmic order they're an
aberration they're a screw up that was
the whole thing with a character a
protege who basically copied the powers
of everybody that he saw and it made him
Bert virtually godlike to the point that
even protege was able to go again go
toe-to-toe with the Living Tribunal and
so the idea here is to basically have
Galactus on trial and say Galactus is
supposed to be the devourer of worlds if
he's not doing this he's not part of the
cosmic order he's not maintaining his
rule he's going against cosmic law
ultimately the Living Tribunal says no
if this is going to be the case with
Galactus then this is basically his
perfect iteration this is his perfect
form he has moved in the direction moved
into his next stage of evolution he's
not violating any laws now the issue
that's made with this is that the Living
Tribunal also establishes that because
of the fact that the all-new
all-different marvel universe and even
multiverse is still new that the cosmic
law is still being made the hierarchy is
still being constructed so for those of
you guys who are asking for a new
hierarchy for all-new all-different
marvel a new cosmic and power hierarchy
we can't do that yet because we don't
know what the hierarchy is and this
plays out when master order and Lord
Kaos kill the Living Tribunal now again
because of the fact that they kill the
tribunal and essentially take his place
what they do in turn is they
on and say we are going to impose our
will we're going to impose our order on
to everything we're going to make the
universe bend to our will it's going to
be how we believe it should be it's
going to function the way that we think
it should now in the midst of all this
we end up coming across some sort of
crazy enigmatic kind of energy that
makes its presence known to the
ultimates now of course as this energy
has fought by The Ultimates as his
energy begins to coalesce we end up
finding out that this energy is the
shaper of worlds now this is really kind
of cool because the shaper of worlds is
basically a cosmic cube that went crazy
now the funny thing about this is that
the shaper of worlds cannot really do
anything on its own because it's a
cosmic cube a cosmic cube is basically
bound to the intention of the person who
wields it and so it would be like if I
gave you a pencil all right the pencil
can only do what you do with it the
pencil can't draw by itself the pencil
needs you to pick it up and draw
something on a piece of paper and that's
how a cosmic cube works the cosmic you
can't do anything on its own this shaper
of worlds is the exact same way now what
the shaper basically tells us is that
when it came into existence in the
Marvel Universe before Secret Wars that
it basically functioned in all the ways
that we saw it do its whole thing that
would be a villain it would show up it
would do some crazy things here and
there but when the collapse of the
multiverse took place the shaper of
worlds was effectively assured outside
all space and time and when it did it
saw something out there it's off force
out there that nobody knew about and so
because of that it basically confined
this confined him down to it to a
singular point where a more or less
drove him insane but it also made his
energy signature you know incorporeal
and so what it's been doing is basically
reconstituting itself down to a
recognizable form which isn't you know
that in turn harnessed by Adam Brashear
and The Ultimates more or less for
safekeeping and so because of the fact
that the Living Tribunal has essentially
been killed the first step of master
order and Lord chaos is bonding
themselves into the being logos and then
to also try to basically force Galactus
back into being the devourer of worlds
in terms of them individually they're
not able to force Galactus back into the
position of being the devourer of worlds
and so for the most part they launch an
attack but nothing really happens
Galactus just fixes himself and then he
calls it a day but what al viewing also
does here is he invokes a guy by the
name of Jim Henson now Jim Henson is a
new creation he's something newly
introduced by Al Ewing and so was a lot
of the stuff that we're going to see
with a group called the Troubleshooters
and these are basically
of recruits that have been organized
under Jim Tinson for the purpose of
operating us like a black ops team or
like a recon team and intelligence team
now initially Jim Tintin is contacted by
Phil Vaughn of course we know him as the
governmentally the liaison who's been
tasked with monitoring the Ultimates of
course the reason why the government did
that is because of the amount of power
the Ultimates possess and the idea that
they were basically running around in
space without anybody keeping an eye on
them and so what this does is this
basically reveals to us that both Phil
vaad and Jim Henson were part of a group
called the first Eternity battalion now
we're not gonna learn a whole lot about
them but we're gonna learn a little bit
more here in a little here in a little
while just enough to kind of give us
some context and that's really about it
and it makes sense just because these
are characters that are being introduced
it would really be way too much
information if we got origin stories for
all these guys over the course of a
six-issue story which is it'd be way too
long the way too convoluted way too
confusing anyone throw everybody off and
so we're basically just kind of given
this a little bit of information about
Jim Henson but the idea here is that
from Phil Watts perspective Jim Henson
as well as this guy Simon rod skoe which
will we'll learn about him here in a
minute
um the idea is that because the
Ultimates are more or less running
around with any without anybody keeping
an eye on them and because of the fact
that they basically disbanded and then
reformed against the wishes of the
federal government the Troubleshooters
are being sent in to monitor the
ultimate secretly to investigate their
base of operations to make sure they're
not up to anything nefarious and to also
essentially bring them in and say you
guys are not supposed to be banded
together you guys have to answer to the
government in terms of why you're doing
this now jumping back to master order
and lord chaos again because of the fact
that they failed in their attempts to to
force Galactus back into his normal
state we end up having Connor Sims
whisked away by Galactus as soon as the
Living Tribunal died basically the like
just said okay these are popping off
things are going crazy get out of here
go get the ultimate to tell them what's
going on that was one of the coolest
moments was really basically just kind
of whisked him away because that's when
you know that things were getting
incredibly serious and that's the
coolest thing is because Galactus is
such an imposing character and Marvel
Comics such a powerful character and
Marvel Comics that when he's with his
Herald and things begin to sort of panic
you can almost kind of see him looking
at the situation a little fearful and
just kind of whispering - Connor Sims
look man go tell the Ultimates what's
going on before things are too late and
like whisking the ultimate you know
whiskey
way to go find the ultimate so it's
really cool because it's a great way to
show us the gravity of the situation now
because master order and Lord chaos were
unable to force their their power on to
on to Galactus they travel to the
in-between and remember the in-betweener
was created by master order and Lord
chaos for the purpose of basically
having a balance of physical
representation of the balance between
order and chaos but by absorbing the
in-betweener into them and then with
with master order absorbing you know
Lord chaos into himself what basically
ends up happening here is we end up
having a new leaf or a newly created
being formed called logos and this is
really kind of a cool idea because now
what it gives us is a new cosmic entity
and it's actually pretty interesting
because the first thing this cosmic
entity does is it looks around and it
says all these Celestials and so on and
so forth they're all aberrations they're
all things that do not need to exist
they're held there holdovers from the
way things used to be a new order must
be maintained a new universe has been
created and the cosmic landscape must
reflect this new universe and so what
happens is logos obliterates every last
one of the Celestials save for one and
the one celestial that is saved is
essentially the one above all of the of
the Celestials now this brings into
sharp relief the question of the one
overall head as a function this is a
super simple answer there's two versions
of the one above all there is the god of
the Marvel multiverse the one that we
tried to kill and failed and then
there's the one above all celestial
they're two distinctly different beings
don't worry people get them confused all
the time so it's cool don't don't sweat
it if you're kind of a little thrown off
by it you're not the only one a lot of
folks kind of get thrown off by that but
we'll just call him the top celestial
just for the sake of keeping things easy
even then this is really the only time
we see him but top celestial is
basically saved by the never Queen now
the never Queen was actually a dance
lock creation as far as I'm aware and
she originally appeared in Silver Surfer
but the never Queen was really more of
like a plot device that Dan Slott made
but because she was established to be a
cosmic entity she's basically been ruled
over and all the other stories that
involve cosmic entities but the never
Queen basically exists outside of all
things that currently exist and she
represents things that could possibly
exist so again we're really getting into
the realm of hypotheticals so on and so
forth but because of the fact that
everything happening in the universe is
taking place in the present she's always
one step ahead she's always in the
future she
always represents the possibility of
what could be so the never Queen is
composed of the possibility of you going
left instead of going right that never
Queen is composed of the possibility of
you waking up instead of dying
she's just composed of all the
possibilities that could exist that's
what makes up who she is so again it's
kind of crazy but it but she fits
perfectly into the realm of abstract
characters now the problem with this is
that in the midst of the Troubleshooters
residing inside the base of operations
for the Ultimates
their presence culminates in the
Ultimates arriving to see them there and
so what is up happening is the Ultimates
face off against the Troubleshooters and
it's kind of a cool conflict to see it's
not wildly significant but it's cool to
see their various counter balances but
what is up happening here is Jim Henson
keeps tapping it as something called the
sigh force now we don't know a whole lot
about what the sigh force is we simply
just know that it's there but the big
guy who's really important to focus on
here is Razvi this guy initially goes
against a blue Marvel Adam Brashear and
then easily overpowers him and the
biggest question to ask here is that if
Adam Brashear is one of the most
powerful beings in existence in Marvel
Comics then how much more powerful could
Rosco really be if he's going to
overpower Adam Brashear in his entirety
so again what seems to be the indication
is that this Rosco guy is a guy who's
not supposed to be here ed he's someone
who's a bit of an aberration he's a guy
that's not what he appears to be and so
again in the middle of this battle
between The Ultimates and the trouble
shooters logo's returns to Galactus and
forces him back into being the devourer
of worlds and when I first read this I
was just like wow like it blew my mind
because logos is basically like you're
going to go back to being who you were
whether you want to be or not and so
it's kind of this impurity that spilled
all over Galactus and one of the final
words he says is I hunger now the
depiction of Galactus as he appears here
in terms of how he's drawn is designed
to be that way he looks screwed up he
looks wrong he looks corrupted that's
exactly how it's supposed to be that's
how he's supposed to appear simply
because of the fact that this is not his
normal state he's being forced back into
an artificial state because remember he
basically evolved into his next stage
which was the life bringer basically the
ability to create life as opposed to
destroying it though what also ends up
happening here is that Rosco emerges in
the midst of this fight with the
ultimate and basically becomes this
sheer wrecking force absolutely
decimating every scene
member of The Ultimates now of course
Galactus basically teleports back to
where everybody's located at what almost
immediately Falls and so what we end up
finding out is that with regards to
Roscoe being here with regards to you
know all these different things that are
going on with logos with master order
lord chaos all of this has basically
been implemented itself by something
called the first firmament and this is
when we start to get into the timeline
of things making sense now it kind of
boggled me a little bit because up until
this point in the story things seem very
disjointed all over the place and it was
a good read well I would rather have
this timeline you know at the beginning
of the story
that being said having it at the end
actually makes it a little more
impactful just because of the fact that
it gives us all the answers that we've
been looking for all this time and so
what happens as al Ewing goes all the
way back to the very beginning of all
things now in Marvel Comics we knew this
was the case right like you know before
Secret Wars you had Marvel the
multiverse all that kind of stuff the
universe that you think of when you
think of Marvel so when Spiderman first
appeared when the Incredible Hulk first
appeared Iron Man all that kind of good
stuff of course we had the universe that
Galactus hailed from the multiverse that
I guess really the universe before the
current version of the multiverse and
then we had you know all these different
universes and so on and so forth dating
back to the point when the very first
universe came into existence somewhere
along the line in Marvel Comics what we
end up finding out here is that this
being the first firmament basically
created life as the singular
representation of the very very first
universe the firmament made a group
called the aspirants and what Al Ewing
is drawing on here is he's actually
drawing on Karen Gillan I think it is
his run of Iron Man which was absolutely
amazing but one of the things that
curing Gillan established was that at
some point in the history of the
universe that there were a massive
number of Celestials but there was a war
that had broken out between the
Celestials and the aspirants now we
didn't know what the aspirants look like
we didn't know their history all we knew
is that they were just some group with
power equal to that of the Celestials
and it resulted in the aspirants
basically overtaking the Celestials
pushing them to the brink of almost
complete and total extinction in an act
of desperation the Celestials created
something called the god killer armor
and the god killer armor basically
obliterated the aspirants and pushed
them to the brink of all destruction now
that is the most recent version of the
Marvel Universe so we'll call that the
seventh
Marvel multiverse in this first Marvel
multiverse what we're seeing here right
now this is basically just a war that
broke out between the asteroids and the
Celestials which is always destined to
do but in this war that initially broke
out it led to the destruction of that
universe and when the universe was
reborn as the second universe the the
first firm of it basically spread out
and so what we basically get up to this
point is that there was a singular
universe with the destruction of the of
the first universe it exploded into a
multiverse and so with the creation of
this multiverse came the cosmic entities
that we know that eternity and so on and
so forth and so because of that in this
basically the second multiverse things
progressed the wars repeated yet again
the war between the aspirants the war
between the Celestials it kept happening
over and over and over again throughout
every single multiverse that was created
up to the seventh multiverse which went
into secret Wars which went into the 8th
multiverse as we have it right now but
despite all these different conflicts
that had happened the first firmament
was always in the back this energy force
was just always in the back watching
everything unfold and the first
firmament was plotting its revenge was
plotting its way to basically eliminate
all things in existence we take the
universe back unto itself and then be
the sole universe in existence basically
consolidating everything back down and
so because of this the first firmament
began to launch a series of campaigns
aimed at basically destabilizing all
things in existence and trying to create
aberrations that would make eternity
extremely weak due to the fact that
following the new formation of the
universe or the multiverse eternity was
already in a weakened state so it would
allow the allow the first storm into
basically overpower eternity put it in
Chains and then begin the process of
destroying everything now the reason why
I say that a Ewing is basically going
through and offering changes is because
historically speaking in Marvel Comics
eternity was the physical representation
of a universe and so there were an
infinite number of eternity x' one for
each universe the idea had been toyed
with that there was a singular eternity
that made up the multiverse but there
was nothing to indicate that it was
actually true what al viewing is doing
here is making it true al viewing is
saying now there's a multiversal
eternity there's one eternity that
represents or is the physical embodiment
of the multiverse inside that
multiversal eternity are all the
infinite number of universes and one
eternity for each of those universes so
again it's a little interesting you know
the
but again it basically expands the
marvel cosmology now of course switching
back to the conflict as it exists right
now of course what we end up doing is we
end up having Connor Sims basically
resurrected by the combined efforts of
Monica Rambeau and Adam Brashear and so
because of the fact that Connor Sims is
brought back a Connor Sims basically
containing what's left of the life
bringer energy essentially takes himself
directly to Galactus and merges himself
with Galactus to a degree in the sense
that he disperses himself into Galactus
as a result Galactus is reborn as the
life bringer and then destroys rot slow
and in doing so learns everything that
Ross foe knows which is basically the
first permanent the idea that this first
firmament has struck first that this
entire event everything we've seen up to
this point is the first battle it's the
opening salvo it's the first skirmish
and the first firmament intends to
launch a massive campaign against the
entire multiverse destroying essentially
everything and bringing all things into
existence back into itself and then
being a singular universe unto itself
going forward
okay so getting into this newest story
of The Ultimates a lot of people have
been asking me to cover this the biggest
problem is that Marvel releases their
stories monthly so we've had to wait
like four or five or six months for this
story to finish before we could cover it
that's what's so irritating about the
way Marvel publishes right now because
DC has spoiled me so bad
DC releases bi-weekly for like their
most popular titles and so by the time a
story comes to an end I actually have to
go back and read it again because I
usually forget what happened at the very
beginning but what this story is is
basically something called
eternity work and this focuses on the
idea of what is quite literally a battle
of cosmic entities now what this also
does is it requires us to understand
like the new Marvel cosmic hierarchy and
the way the multiverse works fortunately
you'll find a link down in the
description to that video that I made
quite some time ago and it basically
runs over the new multiverse and all
that kind of good stuff now to brush
back up on that for those of you guys
who just don't have the time or the
inclination to watch it the long and
short of it is that Marvel with The
Ultimates line of stories introduced
something called the first firmament and
what they told us is that in the very
beginning of all things there was just
this singular universe and this universe
was sentient every universe has been
sentient so if the universe could get up
and walk around it would be the first
firmament now the first phone had
created life in the form of beings
called the Celestials and most
know who the Celestials are by this
point they're just these super powerful
beings that are basically responsible
for creating life and different things
like that but the Celestials that were
created by the firmament existed in two
forms those who were faithful to the
firmament and those who were not those
who were faithful were called the
aspirants those who were not were just
called Celestials now what this did is
it basically led to this massive war
like this this giant civil war among
these beings that had enough power to
basically control and manipulate all of
reality itself and so like you would
expect this war quite literally laid
waste to the universe and what ended up
happening is like you picking up a glass
cup and dropping it on the ground the
universe completely shattered now of
course what this did is all these
different shattered pieces became
universes of their own and that was the
explanation of how the multiverse came
into existence now for reasons that are
never explained that multiverse was
destroyed and then recreated and
destroyed and recreated and destroyed
and recreated so on and so forth leading
all the way up to Jonathan Hickman's
collapse of the multiverse and Avengers
and New Avengers and in the start of
all-new all-different marvel
but what Ultimates does in the all new
more on all-new all-different marvel
line of comics is it gives us the first
firmament as this being Miss basically
existed outside of all time and space
and is finally making its return but the
reason why this matters is because we're
talking about a level of power so
extreme that the first firmament was
actually able to quote-unquote
chain up the multiverse now this is when
we start getting into like ad abstract
things for the most part when it comes
to comics things are really easy to
understand when people are able to just
kind of crack open a comic and read
what's going on mostly because of the
fact that when the average person goes
and reads a comic book it's easy to
digest The Incredible Hulk is pissed off
Incredible Hulk is gonna smash stuff
that's super simple but when it comes to
like cosmic entities we're dealing with
abstract we're dealing with a level of
power so extreme that it can literally
result in the destruction of all things
in existence and that's what I want you
to keep in the back of your head what
we're gonna be seeing over the course of
this story is a level of power among
these beings that's so insane that if
one of them were to lose it it would
destroy all things in existence well
except for the Ultimates we'll talk
about them here in a second but that's
basically what this is it's a fight for
all existence the way this opens up is
with Galactus the life bringer now
remember if you're catching up on this
if you haven't seen any of the Ultimates
videos that we've
so far Galactus has always been the
world devourer that was always his thing
he would travel across the cosmos he
would consume worlds that were able to
sustain life he would keep his energies
in check and that was really it with
all-new all-different marvel the first
thing the team of The Ultimates did was
band together and then basically
transformed Galactus into the life
bringer so that he would no longer be a
threat to the universe instead he would
be a force for good instead of a force
for destruction now of course this Saint
Galactus on the path of going through
and just like recreating worlds that he
previously consumed any number of things
that like a superhero with that insane
level of power would possibly do the
problem with this is that once Galactus
learned that the first firmament had
basically returned and this being was of
such an extreme level of power that it
was able to basically chain up the
multiverse Galactus panic now if that
does not give you an indication of how
powerful the first firmament is I don't
know what will because keep in mind with
the power of Galactus he can create life
he can end life he can manipulate the
universe itself I mean he's just a being
really one of the most powerful beings
in existence out there but the idea is
that Galactus had basically been trying
to fight off as best he can and
literally running for his life in almost
every conceivable situation because he'd
been confronted by these beings that
were working for the first firmament
that were equal or superior to his own
power and so what he ended up doing was
actually taking up refuge in a place
that was basically rated by the molecule
man Owen Reese now remember the molecule
man basically sat alongside classic Reed
Richards Franklin Richards and those
guys and they were the ones creating the
new universes in all-new all-different
marvel the idea was that because the
molecule man was so insane in terms of
his abilities he also created kind of
like this pocket universe for himself
and it was a place for him to just kind
of hang out and kind of reside now of
course what we're told by Galactus is
that molecule man had long since
abandoned this place we don't know where
he went - we have no idea what ever
happened to him he had basically just
taken off and so because of this
Galactus basically co-opted this pocket
dimension for himself and then actually
once he emerges he's on the planet of
ego now ego is kind of a weird situation
because in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
which is how most people are being
introduced to his character he is pretty
different than he is in Marvel Comics in
the mobile cinematic universe Marvel
calls him a celestial he's actually not
he's literally just a guy
who had tried to save his planet from a
Sun that was going supernova he
ultimately failed and he actually merged
with all the people on his planet and
the planet itself and that's why he's
called ego the Living Planet now the
funny thing about this is that ego hates
Galactus and the reason for this as
crazy as it sounds is because when
Galactus and ego first fought Galactus
actually attached a rocket to his
back-end and sent him hurtling through
space that's exactly what happened
that's when he learned the whole origin
story of ego the problem with this is
that as powerful as ego is he's only
ever really powerful on his own on his
home planet it would be like if you had
the ability to control whatever was at
your home did if your home could get up
and walk around control whatever it was
you wanted it to do
egos like that with his home planet so
ego for example cannot control earth
with Galactus arriving here because of
the fact that he's exhausted with his
own energies he's not necessarily able
to overpower ego instead it actually
turns into really more of a diplomatic
mission and the reason for this is
because Galactus is travelling around
the cosmos and assembling a team of some
of the most powerful beings in existence
the goal of Galactus is to recruit ego
to his side as just one of many people
who can pull this off now it's Galactus
perfectly aware of the fact that none of
these guys could actually destroy the
first firmament or defeat them it's just
a matter of is it possible for them to
so of course this leads to Galactus
actually modifying using his powers to
modify ego the Living Planet transform
him into ego Prime so he's actually a
full-bodied entity which is cool because
we've never seen this before not only
that once ego is taken by Galactus and
brought to basically the the Eternity
watch is what they call themselves we
end up having a lot of these beings who
are basically some of the most powerful
beings in existence now keep in mind the
cosmic entities as we think of them the
Celestials infinity these characters
they were all destroyed in the last
couple arcs that we covered so Galactus
normally would have reached out to them
but they've all been destroyed and so
because of that is literally him
grabbing whoever's left now some of
these characters are extremely ambiguous
like in Phenom for example we don't know
anything about it but then there's
people like the shaper of worlds and
there's the sigh Hawk now sigh Hawk is
kind of a weird situation because sigh
Hawk was actually created by a guy named
Archie Goodwin back in 1986 and a series
called ciphers that ran for about three
years now
the idea is that he actually hails from
a comic line called new universe which
was relatively popular at the time but
never really regained steam eventually
Warren Ellis tried to relaunch it with
new universal but it's basically as
close as we get to the real world if
people develop powers the idea is that
the psychic the best example I can use
here and this is gonna be a shameless
example the best example I can use here
is like Captain Planet is really yet you
know when the Planeteers combine their
powers they get Captain Planet when the
members of the sci force combine their
powers they get SCI Hawk that's it
that's really all there is it's just a
being of insane psychic power but again
you know it's it's one of those weird
ambiguous scenarios this is kind of
thrown in here and rolled in just
because of the fact that Galactus is
reaching for whatever he can get and so
that's what these guys are they're
basically the leftovers that's really
the best way to call them they're just
kind of you know whatever it is that
they can do to try to stave off this
conflict but it's kind of crazy because
this takes the annihilation / Civil War
concept and expands it to a broader
scale those of you guys who don't know
back when Marvel launched the original
Civil War event you know Captain America
vs Iron Man that was an earth-based
conflict and that was it it was strictly
confined to earth but while that
conflict was going on this villain
Annihilus from the negative zone had
invaded the universe and it was the
craziest thing because like Richard
Ryder who was playing the role of Nova
at the time showed up on earth and is
like what are you guys doing like the
universe is about to be overrun and
destroyed what in the world is going on
like it was it was one of the funniest
things to happen there was really kind
of a cool moment but the idea here is
it's on a much broader scale so while
secret Empire is happening and Hydra
Captain America is like I'm gonna make
the world a better place like all
existence is on the brink of complete
and total collapse and so what we end up
doing here is we actually transition and
we end up finding out that Galactus is
not the only person involved here there
is another being who is involved in
trying to figure out a way to keep this
collapse of the multiverse from
happening and that this being is
actually Reed Richards also known as the
maker alongside the High Evolutionary
now we'll get into the High Evolutionary
Herbert Wyndham here in a second but I
want to talk about the maker because the
maker is really one of the cooler
characters that exists in Marvel Comics
but he's also a character that Marvel's
never really done a whole lot with
outside of the alternate universe in
terms of him crossing over and that
makes sense because there was never a
reason for him to but the idea is of the
maker this version of Reed Richards from
the Ultimate Universe his origin story
is basically what you saw in that
terrible Fox film that has a nine
percent on Rotten Tomatoes which it
rightfully deserves except for Michael B
Jordan he was amazing but the idea is
that this version of Reed was very
similar to his main Marvel counterpart
in the sense that he was a genius he
became part of a think tank eventually
he branched off formed the Fantastic
Four so on and so forth the difference
here is that in 2009 Marvel launched an
event in the Ultimate Universe called
ultimatum and this event was basically
all of the superheroes in the Ultimate
Universe versus Magneto and it was
amazing I liked ultimatum a lot of
people hated it a lot of people did not
like ultimatum at all but I enjoyed
ultimatum it was kind of a cool thing
but this was one of those stories that
was designed to implement a paradigm
shift and one of the things that it saw
was basically Reed Richards in the
Ultimate Universe falling from grace so
to speak his marriage proposal being
rejected by Susan storm so on and so
forth and then eventually becoming a bad
guy and so what this did is that he
really rechristened himself as the maker
now it also led into things like
children of tomorrow which is kind of
cool and honestly I wouldn't mind
covering that I mean I always thought
aspect to the alternate universe we're
always kind of fun and kind of
interesting the problem is that most
people on my channel don't really seem
to care but it's kind of a cool scenario
because he was actually one half of the
equation when it came to Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers that
came a point when ultimate Reed actually
joined the Cabal of Thanos in trying to
destroy different earths across the
multiverse but the idea here is that the
makers actually working alongside
Herbert Wyndham now the High
Evolutionary is actually a guy who
basically evolved his own molecular
structure he was obsessed with the idea
of human evolution now of course
modifying in among his own self he gave
himself basically godlike powers he is a
human being pushed to the extreme of
what humans will most likely become but
he also just kind of became his mad
scientist in the sense that he just kind
of hung out in wundagore mountain and he
basically just created like all these
different things he had like
counter-earth so on and so forth and
that's actually where these guys are
right now they are encounter earth there
basically is basically another earth
that's orbiting but that's kind of the
weird thing and that's the disconnect
because you'll never see counter earth
any other stories in Marvel Comics you
will only see it in this which is one of
the big reasons why people are just kind
of like ok continuities out the window
and marvel because you would think that
if there was another earth orbiting
around the existing earth then somebody
out there would have noticed but it's
kind of a weird scenario because what
they've basically come to the conclusion
of is that with eternity quote-unquote
basically being chained by the first
firmament their goal is to essentially
grab all these different universes and
merge them into one now the belief is
that it will basically empower eternity
it'll make eternity more powerful than
it was before remember eternity is a
living embodiment of the universe and so
the idea is to merge all of these
universes into one and then feed that
energy directly into eternity giving it
the power to escape the first firmament
the problem with this is that we don't
know if it'll really succeed and of
course it does to a degree but the issue
is that it actually coincides with the
maker in my evolutionary watching all
these events on full with regards to
Galactus and his and his eternity watch
facing off against these aspirants these
faithful Celestials to the first firm in
itself and of course where they do the
best they can to face off against these
forces in the end it's really not much
of a battle because we're talking about
a conflict that is extreme in the degree
and so what we end up doing is we
actually transition to black panther and
to a place called the necropolis now the
crazy thing about what Black Panther is
doing is he's actually being pretty
dangerous when it comes to the various
gods and Marvel Comics especially the
Panther God the being that basically
provides Black Panther with his various
abilities the Panther God is pretty
selfish and the Panther gods like look
you will worship me and no one else now
with regards to what Black Panther is
doing the necropolis was actually a
concept that I believe was created by
Jonathan Hickman and it was a way for
Black Panther to actually talk to anyone
who's ever been a black panther in the
history of Wakanda basically him going
to those who have greater experience and
who were wiser than him but if long
since passed away and say what do you
guys think that I should do here now
that fit in nicely with the Black
Panther concept because it allowed to
chala
to basically maintain the autonomy of
what conduct while also seeking outside
counsel and so reaching out to those who
have basically seen where these things
will reside or at the very least who
have a general idea of what the best
road is to take allows him to basically
say look I don't know everything that
that's this
out there I don't know everything that
exists I need your help in figuring
these things out again we'll talk more
about that once we get into Avengers and
new Avengers but the idea is that
because he cannot necessarily go to the
Panther God because they're kind of on
strenuous terms which are courses in his
own comic the idea is that instead he
reaches out to the tiger God and this is
kind of cool because it gives us all
these different Pantheon sees different
animal beings that exist out there but
the tiger God basically emerged when the
first beings came into existence and
while the tiger God does represent the
idea that humans were terrified of
Tigers you know back in the early days
it's also the idea that the tiger God
basically represents the very essence of
what it means for humans to feel fear it
is the the full culmination of
humanity's fear combined into a singular
being but the idea is that Black Panther
really kind of fights against the tiger
God for a second only to basically try
to use surface power now of course this
leads directly to the maker and the High
Evolutionary being successful in their
goal to channel all these universes
energies into eternity and then
ultimately free it but it has a side
effect of bringing in the original
Ultimates and that's where people begin
to look at these things now something
else that I want you to notice here is
that among these original Ultimates is
the ultimate Incredible Hulk and that's
why I say during the events of secret
Empire
that was not Ultimate Hulk that was just
regular Bruce Banner we know that
because he's in this story right now now
it also begs the question you know is
Marvel just kind of blowing you know
throwing continuity out the window which
they seem to be doing and it's entirely
possible but the fact remains here that
because of the fact that these different
universes are all basically coalescing
into one another it allows you know
Galactus and his eternity watch to
actually jump out of all space and time
so they're literally in this white space
they're outside of all things in
existence they can actually watch things
in existence take place now keep in mind
we're talking about beings who are of
the highest order so it's not like you
standing in Las Vegas and trying to see
what's happening in Los Angeles they
have this sort of multiversal cosmic
awareness and so they can stand outside
of the multiverse itself they can stand
outside of all things and still see
what's going on inside the idea here is
that again Galactus begins to hit home
at the concept that if the first Fermin
is not stopped that this first universe
isn't isn't halted did it'll result in
the destruction of all things in
existence which includes all the
remaining cosmic entities death so on
and so forth the cool thing about this
is that it also basically has
ultimate s-- the the newest version of
The Ultimates facing off against their
previous their alternate reality
counterparts now the funny thing about
this is that people look at blue Marvel
Adam Brashear and in a lot of ways he's
kind of a ride off now of course people
have recently on YouTube men talking
about him more and more but basically
blue Marvel is one of Marvel's versions
of Superman that's really it now he's
also a genius in a lot of different ways
but his power is not to be trifled with
and in this instance he knocks out
Ultimate Hulk in one punch that's all it
takes he literally just uppercuts him in
the chin and that's the end of Ultimate
Hulk I mean he's just down now the idea
here is that because he's so empowered
and because he takes out the you know
Ultimate Hulk so fast it immediately
catches the attention of the other
Ultimates the the original Ultimates now
of course they continue fighting on
until America Chavez basically says hey
look were the current Ultimates here in
this universe now it's basically the
Avengers from one universe leading the
Avengers from another universe and at
that point it just creates a cease fire
it is this classic Ultimates Captain
America basically saying everybody stop
everybody stand out if they are
effectively Avengers and we're basically
Avengers then we need to talk this out
and figure out what's going on the
problem with this is that by combining
their efforts together they come to the
realization that what a maker did was by
freeing eternity it basically allowed
eternity to be consumed by the first
ferment to literally allow the first
moment to bolster its own power and so
inadvertently he actually achieved the
opposite of what he was shooting for now
none of this matters anyway just because
of the fact that the maker as we see him
here is just as arrogant as he ever was
when he was in the alternate universe
and so because of this it literally
leads to him just being destroyed by by
spectrum this living source of energy
that's all she is she's energy in a
physical form and that's really all
there is to it he gets wiped out pretty
fast now I would argue the reason why
this is done is because of the fact that
the maker is also still going on in
infamous Iron Man so again this is the
whole continuity thing this is why these
are getting kind of weird for those guys
had never read DCU this is the problem
people had when it came to DC Comics
characters appear in one story they
don't appear in the other there's no
continuity we don't know went what story
when these stories take place if one
follows the other it gets really weird
and it gets really bonkers and it gets
really bananas but the idea here is
because of the fact that eternity has
been consumed by the
firmament the goal of the Ultimates as
they exist is to combine a combination
of their powers as well as their brains
to task and actually jumpstart eternity
again and what this does is it brings
him back not only that because he's
effectively resurrected here it also
brings about the reintroduction of all
these different cosmic entities because
remember they are all effectively
children of eternity that's the way it
works when it came to Marvel Comics do
you have eternity the embodiment of the
universe and then like you know a man
and a woman giving birth to a kid
eternity just sort of popping out all
these cosmic entities different things
like that those Celestials who were
destroyed by the first firmament are
basically resurrected here they're
essentially brought back and so again
it's kind of eternity giving birth to
all these things bringing all these
entities back again and so because of
that we also end up finding out that the
queen of Nevers had actually taken the
last of the Celestials before they were
destroyed and so this one celestial that
did survive gave birth to even more
Celestials and so again it's basically
this return to familiarity it's
everything resetting itself back to the
way it was before just by virtue of
eternity popping up so again it's really
just this idea that this being that
literally exists as the culmination of
the universe is returning the universe
back to the way that it's supposed to be
now of course things wrap up pretty fast
here and it's actually kind of
disappointing the way it wraps up so
fast the reason for this is because of
the fact that if you're not familiar
with what Marvel's doing right now
Marvel's basically doing legacy and
generations and the idea is there was so
much negative backlash to secret Empire
there was so much negative backlash to
Marvel basically switching characters
over are getting rid of classic
characters replacing them with new ones
the Marvel hit the panic button and
instead they said okay fine we need to
basically bring back everything the way
that it used to be and so this story
believe it or not this is actually
Ultimates to issue number 100 this is
legacy numbering what Marvel originally
wanted was ultimately 7 through 12
that's what the story was slated for but
because of the whole remembering thing
it's been shortened by two issues and
then in turn they've just tacked on
you know this ending sort of ramrodded
it into the conclusion of the story so
it was supposed to drag on longer as far
as I can tell but it's not so things
basically just end the first firmament
is just defeated right off the bat
that's really it and then that just kind
of
the story things just kind of get reset
to normal and that's that is this quick
you know super into a story that should
have otherwise been drawn out by a
couple more issues and actually probably
would have had more of a successful
closure to it but the fact remains with
this particular thing it's it's really
just things going back to normal to a
degree go like just still remains a life
bringer but again because of the fact
that this takes place before the
conclusion of secret Empire what it does
is it just shows the rest of the the
members of The Ultimates going through
and doing their own thing Carol Danvers
taking out hydra black panther going
back to going back to what Conda with
the tiger God in his possession
presumably meaning that he's going to
start drawing his power from a new
entity but again it's one of these weird
scenarios because the story just kind of
ends it just kind of comes to a
conclusion but with that being said guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain and make sure you guys
with the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
Marvel battle lines the game that you
can download by clicking the link in the
description that will take you to the
App Store where you can download it for
the iPhone and the iPad or where you can
go to the Google Play Store and download
it for Android devices this game
launches with over 200 DD cards that you
can collect and build decks from
different superheroes and supervillains
the favorites were pretty much all there
I am an Black Panther venom and Squirrel
Girl just to name a few and the game
features this expansive roster of
characters that true Marvel thews iasts
like myself would recognize such as
Deathlok Man Thing and grin pool now
since this is a Marvel product the game
features gorgeous comic quality artwork
and stunning visual effects and the
marvel battle lines features a variety
of modes including a single-player
campaign with an original story crafted
by Marvel writer Alex Irvine a special
ops mode in challenge modes and of
course a competitive PvP arena where you
can compete against other players to
move up the rankings so make sure you
guys check the link down in the
description and I will see you all in
the next video peace
[Music]